alors trois mois après les faits déjà
comment tu vas me michel mas disons que
mon état plus que toujours un truc qu au
bras comment ça se passe et une attelle
bas comme j'ai eu le tendon sectionné on
l'a ressouder avec une encre où on a
ressoudé monfils est du coup et après
l'ag a forcément une rééducation faire
trois mois après tu as encore un jouet
je crois que dans pas longtemps je
pourrais je pourrais m'en séparer
complètement et est dans la tête comment
ça va c'est moi et au corps suis remis
plus vite que la tête je crois dans la
tête tu es comment c'est toujours
compliqué mais on fait en sorte que
quand il allait encaisser quoi que tu te
reste traumatisée tu as tes voilà qu'ils
repensent tu arrives à dormir
normalement paribas mais c'est vraiment
un match que j'ai un peu de mal mais je
crois que quoi qu est ce qui ce qui est
bien dans la nuit qui se tapent tel
talent angoisse t ce jeu c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs que je me fais suivre là
dessus mais tu t'es fait sud après
l'agression que tu as décidé de te faire
suivre pour pour essayer de douala de
surmonter dès que j'ai compris que tout
seul ça risque d'être compliqué je
préfère je pense que j'en ai besoin
et puis qu'est-ce que tu te fais suivre
puis qu'est-ce que tu essaies de
vraiment de d'essayer de passer à autre
chose et c'est quoi essayez d'enlever
toutes ces mauvaises images qui a dans
ta tête tout et c'est plutôt de ne plus
être traumatisé peut-être quand tu vois
un policier parce que je sais que
c'était c'était ce qui est traumatisé
dès que tu voyais un uniforme
c'était un petit peu on stresse
c'est que c'est pas évident du coup
j'essaie de me battre contre ça tout ça
c'est vraiment difficile
jeux jeux ça me fait beaucoup de bien
d'ailleurs de pouvoir évacuer tout ça
donc dans ce cas essayer d'en d'évacuer
tout ça de way alors est ce qu est ce
que tu a pardonné aux policiers je pense
que lors du pardon c'est je pense pas
que ce soit maintenant
aujourd'hui moi je ce que je voudrais
c'est c'est que l'anc est ce fini ce
qu'on puisse la requête est en cours
est ce que quand tu croises des
policiers dans la rue est ce que est ce
qu'il y en a peut-être connu quittons
nous parler ou est-ce que temps ça s'est
passé ce que c'est on a envie de savoir
aussi ce qu'est des policiers qui sont
du devoir qui ont dit oui on comprend
que tu fais à traumatiser est ce que
c'est important de le dire aux
téléspectateurs aussi pour qu'ils
comprennent que tous les politiques
voilà sont pas des dépouilles c'est ça
qu'il faut le dire oui michel sait pas
du tout ce qu'ils pensent parce que
est-ce que tu avec des témoignages de
policiers qui m'ont dit on est avec toi
et voilà on cautionne pas ce qui s'est
passé
oui je ce sens la difficulté pour eux de
pouvoir s'exprimer normalement mais oui
j'ai pas mal de policiers de gendarmes
aussi qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord du
tout avec les agissements de ce qu'ils
quittent on dit de me remercier souvent
c'est vrai ouais ils disent pas comment
il est tombé amoureux mur qui traverse
d'abord parce que c'est ce que je dis
souvent quand j'ai les policiers des
gendarmes sur le plateau je le redis ce
genre d'agissements ça leur fait
énormément de mal et c'est vrai que
derrière eux ils ont beaucoup plus de
mal à faire leur travail derrière donc
c'est pour ça qu'il te remercie pour
avoir mis cette lui mais cette affaire
en lumière et pour avoir dénoncé ce qui
s'était passé
ouais enfin taux plus je pense que c'est
plus
pour avoir fait la part des choses
d'accord c'est ça aussi c'est ce que tu
avais dit sur ce plateau continues tu
avais dit voilà moi j'en veux à ses
policiers là mais j'en veux pas la
police et avait appelé tous les voilà
tous les gens qui nous regardent
anpaa voilà s'en prendre à la police et
que tu avais dit que la majorité des
policiers étaient des gens bien et que
toi tu étais peut-être tombé sur les
dégâts qui faisait mal leur boulot
je pense que c'est nécessaire de le dire